- [Instructor] What we're
going to do in this video
is think about limits involving
trigonometric functions.
So let's just start with a
fairly straightforward one.
Let's find the limit as x
approaches pi of sine of x.
Pause the video and see if
you can figure this out.
Well, with both sine of x and cosine of x,
they are defined for all real numbers,
so their domain is all real numbers.
You can put any real number in here for x
and it will give you an output.
It is defined.
And they are also continuous
over their entire domain,
in fact, all of the trigonometric
functions are continuous
over their entire domain.
And so for sine of x,
because it's continuous,
and is defined at sine of pi,
we would say that this
is the same thing as
sine of pi,
and sine of pi, you might already know,
is equal to zero.
Now we could do a similar
exercise with cosine of x,
so if I were to say what's
the limit as x approaches,
I'll just take an arbitrary
angle, x approaches pi over four
of cosine of x?
Well once again,
cosine of x is defined
for all real numbers,
x can be any real number.
It's also continuous.
So for cosine of x, this
limit is just gonna be cosine
of pi over four,
and that is going to be equal
to square root of two over two.
This is one of those useful angles
to know the sine and cosine of.
If you're thinking degrees,
this is a 45 degree angle.
And in general, if I'm dealing
with a sine or a cosine,
the limit as x approaches a of sine of x
is equal to sine of a.
Once again, this is going
to be true for any a,
any real number a.
And I can make a similar
statement about cosine of x.
Limit as x approaches a of cosine of x
is equal to cosine of a.
Now, I've been saying it over and over,
that's because both of their
domains are all real numbers,
they are defined for all
real numbers that you put in,
and they're continuous
on their entire domain.
But now, let's do slightly more involved
trigonometric functions,
or ones that aren't defined
for all real numbers, that
their domains are constrained
just a little bit more.
So let's say if we were to take the limit
as x approaches pi of tangent of x.
What is this going to be equal to?
Well, this is the same thing as the limit
as x approaches pi.
Tangent of x is sine
of x over cosine of x.
And so both of these are defined for pi
and so we could just substitute pi in.
And we just wanna ensure
that we don't get a zero
in the denominator, because
that would make it undefined.
So we get sine of pi
over cosine of pi which is
equal to zero over negative one,
which is completely fine.
If it was negative one over
zero, we'd be in trouble.
But this is just gonna be equal to zero.
So that works out.
But if I were to ask
you, what is the limit
as x approaches pi over
two of tangent of x?
Pause the video and try to work that out.
Well, think about it.
This is the limit as x
approaches pi over two
of sine of x over cosine of x.
Now sine of pi over two is one,
but cosine of pi over two is zero.
So if you were to just substitute in,
this would give you one over zero.
And one way to think
about it is pi over two
is not in the domain of tangent of x.
And so this limit actually
turns out, it doesn't exist.
In general, if we're
dealing with the sine,
cosine, tangent, or cosecant,
secant, or cotangent,
if we're taking a limit to a point
that's in their domain,
then the value of the limit
is going to be the same thing as the value
of the function at that point.
If you're taking a limit to a point
that's not in their domain,
there's a good chance that
we're not going to have a limit.
So here, there is no limit.
And the way to do that is that pi over two
is not in tangent of x's domain.
If you were to graph
tan of x, you would see
a vertical asymptote at pi over two.
Let's do one more of these.
So let's say the limit as x
approaches pi of cotangent of x,
pause the video and see
if you can figure out
what that's going to be.
Well, one way to think about it,
cotangent of x is one over tangent of x,
it's cosine of x over sine of x.
This is a limit as x approaches pi
of this.
And is pi in the domain of cotangent of x?
Well, no, if you were
just to substitute pi in,
you're gonna get negative one over zero.
And so that is not in the
domain of cotangent of x.
If you were to plot it, you
would see a vertical asymptote
right over there.
And so we have no limit.
We have no limit.
So once again, this is
not in the domain of that,
and so good chance that we have no limit.
When the thing we're taking the limit to
is in the domain of the
trigonometric function,
we're going to have a defined limit.
And sine and cosine in
particular are defined
for all real numbers
and they're continuous
over all real numbers.
So you take the limit
to anything for them,
it's going to be defined
and it's going to be
the value of the function at that point.